be hectic but in a school zone the law
is written to try and keep those
students safe but people are reporting
that drivers are breaking laws around a
Northwest Valley School Ryan mathie
shows us how that could be putting
elementary students there in danger
why'd the student cross the road well
here it's to get to Sandra Lee Thompson
Elementary School on the other side but
parents and crossing guards here say it
is increasingly becoming less safe
20 minutes of chaos it's like a
thunderous herd that's how crossing
guard Fred hubs describes the moments
before and after the bell rings at
Sandra Lee Thompson Elementary but
specifically I'm sure that many of the
people do not
there you go he's worried about the
u-turns at this specific intersection of
Campbell and Severance in the Northwest
Valley it's in the school zone where Hub
says and by 2 20
some
60 to 70 kids plus parents and siblings
have crossed it's earned that may be
more convenient for dropping off and
picking up kids but is illegal and could
be dangerous Nevada law prohibits
u-turns and areas designated as school
zones at least 30 minutes before and
after school's in session and anytime
children are present
but the turns keep coming and the kids
keep Crossing have you ever seen a kid
walk they don't and you have kids
crossing here and they make a u-turn
going into them it's a mess every day
and some parents choosing a different
way to get their kids to school because
of it I just don't feel comfortable with
her like walking across there's no stop
sign either so they just go trying to
maintain the traffic trying to maintain
the kids trying to keep the people out
of the crosswalk
Ryan Matthew reporting there so
according to a local Law Group a typical
fine for doing a U-turn like that here
in Las Vegas is about 230 dollars it
also carries with it three demerit
points on your license so 12 or more
points in a year could lead to a
six-month license suspension